a ver esto primero que nada confirma las
teorías de que las fuerzas armadas rusas
ya han consumido prácticamente
una proporción digamos imprudente de sus
top de misiles cruceros tanto de
lanzamiento aéreo naval o terrestre y de
la misma forma tampoco cuentan con la
capacidad de mantener un esfuerzo aéreo
debido a la calidad de las defensas
antiaéreas ucranianas y al consumo de
horas de turbina y de munición por parte
de su propia fuerza aérea esto es una
forma económica de continuar una guerra
que nunca estuvo pensada para durar todo
esto y que bajo ningún punto de vista se
pensó que las fuerzas armadas rusas
tendrían los problemas que están
evidenciando a estas a estas alturas ya
cerca de ocho meses de operaciones de
combate continuas y en las cuales ya
claramente comienzan a perder terreno